you know I don't know why this has
gotten so much attention the Democrat
did something illegal at the U.S Capitol
and I think he deserves 22 years in
prison just like that proud boy guy who
wasn't even at the Capitol because that
would be sort of an equal application of
Justice you have a tweet here uh from a
political reporter named Olivia beavers
news representative Jamal Bowman
Democrat from New York was caught on
camera pulling the Canon fire alarm of
head ahead of his this motion to adjourn
the vote as Democrats tried to delay the
CR vote multiple sources tell me we have
reached out to him for comment we
haven't reviewed the footage ourselves
well Hallelujah Olivia you are in luck
lady because there are cameras at the
Capitol and Hot Diggity Dog they took a
picture of Jamal Bowman pulling the fire
alarm no one else in the history of the
world has ever pulled a fire alarm to
open a door it says in case of emergency
only and you pull the firearm you're not
going to believe and I'm not a
scientician but I've been around the
block when you pull a fire alarm the
fire alarm goes off it doesn't open a
door it doesn't open a window it doesn't
flush a toilet it just turns on the fire
alarm that's how it works but
Bowman is a Democrat and he will skate
by so here he is explaining what he
thought was happening
just in a rush to go vote man that's all
it was are you afraid of any
repercussions either from leadership or
from Legally to California I mean listen
I'll take responsibility for what I did
you know but like I said I was in a rush
to go vote and uh you know investigation
will will sort everything else out have
you talked to Jeffries about it oh yeah
of course let's stay long ago how was
that conversation well I gotta keep that
between me and the leader so I'm not
going to share that publicly yo bro I
was in a rush man sure I pulled a fire
alarm it had nothing to do with opening
the door or anything I was just in a
rush trying to do my job I
mean it's just so ridiculous
[Music]